[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link
and I'm here alone this week at the
round table of dim lighting I'm holding
down to Fort
you know I went out of town and uh
red did an episode without me and I'm
like okay all right fine if I can do
that too I can do that too
uh and I'm doing that now and I
appreciate you listening and giving me
your best wishes as we embark on this
solo journey of potential chaos
Jenna you ready for this I am I know
that uh we put out a prompt saying hey
it's your it's it's your chance to ask
me questions and uh Rhett doesn't get
away yet
so let's see what y'all got for me we're
going to dig into some voicemails we're
going to dig into some tweets
and uh I'm an open book
I guess
it depends on where you want to go let's
just let's let's click into this
voicemail
oh yeah and I have to hit play here too
I'm ready
hey link I think Sam's Club which is
obviously the best place to ask you
something
um I was wondering how you choose your
frames your glasses frames
um because I know it can be a very
personal thing
very specific so I was wondering what
factors
inspire you to pick your glasses frames
and why you choose what you choose
um yeah I thought that'd be a great
question okay bye
thanks for thinking of me in the Sam's
Club I mean there's so many things that
you could think of everywhere you're
looking there's bulk versions of stuff
at least that's my understanding it's
been a long time since I've been in like
the bulk version of Walmart
um even Costco and am I saying that
right every time I say Costco
people like you say that funny you say
Costco funny
but is there anybody here today who
would say that no
Costco right Jenna right that's exactly
how you say it Costco
um did you just say a difference did you
I think you just corrected me no I said
it how I thought you were saying it and
I said Costco Costco yeah I feel like
I'm agreeing with you
Christy came home the other day and she
was um uh she said I went to Costco with
a friend of mine
and we don't you know we don't we don't
really do Costco I think it's because we
don't have space to store multiple of
stuff
and my garage is very important you just
can't throw multiple of stuff in my
garage it may be okay with it unless
it's behind a closed cabinet and all
those cabinets are allocated so this is
my life and this is my garage and if my
garage isn't right my life ain't right
so I not happy about Costco when I heard
that Christy had gone now there's one
exception
I got cases of Topo Chico just just
piled up in my garage but I do it in a
neat way
I do it in an orderly way and so
whenever I walk by it I have this sense
of security no matter what goes down in
the world
I have at least I don't know anywhere
from
two to probably a six week supply of
Topo Chico
at any moment like that
that keeps me
that keeps me on the on on my path
on my Meandering path
so yeah she comes back from Costco
and I'm like well tell me about it it's
been so long since I've done something
like that because I'm an internet
celebrity you know I just can't I just
can't Costco
that's a joke that's not I already told
you the reason
so that now you know that that secondary
reason is just a joke
you know
um
did you get any of the samples she ain't
getting no samples
they still do samples she says she just
stayed away from them that's the only
thing I remember liking about Costco
and she said they sell coffins now
freaking caskets
like
I mean that's like the opposite effect
of me walking by my Topo Chico like
going you know you you go to Costco just
to escape reality
don't you
you because nowhere else on Earth is
there is is so much stuff stockpiled
unless you're in some weird bunker
somewhere and that's not a good vibe
like I ain't never been in a bunker
that's that's the good vibe
um what was my point oh yeah you
strolling down the Costco you're trying
to get that good vibe feeling like that
free sample feeling and then all of a
sudden what is what is that
is that a death box
in multiple colors
I don't know is this one NASCAR themed I
don't you know I didn't ask any
follow-up questions because I freaking
I don't want to hear about caskets at
Costco so she's striking out on samples
she's foul Balling on the
caskets and here I am knowing no other
baseball metaphor
what does she buy
um
I can't even freaking remember what she
bought
uh but you can you can you can drop you
can drop fifteen hundred dollars on a
decent pink casket
my sources are telling me
um
I remember nothing that she bought I'm
experienced I think she just went to say
she went with the friend you know
because you got to use the you got to
use that person's card
I'm talking about glasses right you
asked me about glasses
oh we're going to start off with some
controversy here
um my glass my go-to glasses that I've
had for years so I mean
how long have I had those the last
glasses that I've had it could be a
decade
it could be I was very attached to those
glasses they became a part in my face
and then they broke
they freaking
got brittle they got brittle bone
syndrome
or something
the glasses version of that
I did and I feel like you know what I
should have taken better care of them
and I knew this day was coming because I
went back to the place years after
buying my original pair
I'll go back to this place
um
shout out to Society of the spectacle
and I went there and I was like I'm so
attached to these glasses that I'm
afraid if something happens to them do
you have another pair and they did have
another pair
um
their Lai works I believe is the brand
but um
so I bought the pair I bought a backup
pair and then I kept them in my car
or I had them in my car
and um I actually don't think
they had cut they they didn't have the
prescription lenses in them because
something that I was doing
I needed to wear contacts but then I
wanted to steal my glasses or maybe I
just didn't want to pay for the lenses
this is what you're gonna get this type
of Meandering [__] this is I mean
it could have been around no buddy
system was the other glasses it was
those clear glasses that I got
I know that I bought them just because I
was so attached to him I needed a backup
um
and I I had him in the car in my
freaking driveway
and then I get in my car one morning to
come to work
and I'm like looking through my console
I'm like
my sunglasses are gone
because I usually put them on
before I drive
I don't get people who don't wear
sunglasses this is a tangent
but friggin
wear sunglasses I mean my granddad what
he yeah he had macular degeneration and
that that does there is a genetic
component to that so I'm I'm all about
taking care of my my eyeballs
and sunglasses are a big part of that
um so I'm pretty
fastidious about wearing my sunglasses
but like I talked to my kids they get in
the car I'm like what do you want some
sunglasses it's bright out here we're
driving around you're squinting I think
I have a pair in here that aren't
prescription you can put no no no my
kids refuse to wear sunglasses I mean
you know you're
I got to talk to Lincoln about this
again now that I'm thinking about it
because he's he's 18. you know he's an
adult
ish
and he needs to be wearing sunglasses I
mean it's that's it's if he thought it
was an adult thing to do well now you're
an adult man Step Up protect your eyes
have more visibility there's some
there's a safety component to this
two it's like you're driving down the
road you don't want to be squinting I
dropped Lando off for school today and
he was like and he crosses the street in
front of me and I can tell that there
were cars coming and then they're
driving into the sunlight
and me and all of my wisdom I'm thinking
well he's probably not at 13 which is
okay I have enough time to Dart across
the street before these cards get here
but he's not realizing that the cars
can't see him because of the squint
Factor unless they're wearing sunglasses
you need to be wearing sunglasses I'm
saving a life right now
somebody is deciding to wear sunglasses
because of me and I feel good about that
and you know while I'm at it sign up on
the bone marrow registry
be the match be the match dot org we're
saving lives today where are you Rhett
we freaking you're freaking out you're
you're on a beach somewhere in Canada
where Cayman Islands
what a jerk
what a jerk I'm sitting here saving
lives
with the simple things in life
like like signing up for a registry all
you got to do is it's just a little swab
so you swab your mouth right right
that's all I do that's all you did and
then if you get a match you know you do
more but like then it's worth it
the barrier to entry is so small and you
can get sunglasses pretty cheap too low
barrier to entry with the sunglasses
thing and I also tell them I'm like
listen
it's a it's a way to express yourself
you know it's fashion on your face
and it's not a it's not regular glasses
that you can get you can get trapped in
some regular glasses you can wear them
for decades and they can become part of
your face and then when they break
and your second pair
that you were keeping in your car were
stolen along with your sunglasses out of
your own damn driveway
like I mean just bend me over pull my
britches down like I felt so violated
you know it was like
this is my driveway
what you what it's a dead end freaking
Street I live on a cul-de-sac what are
you doing
yeah I'm just I'm just walking on the
street I'm just pulling on doorknobs man
I'm just pulling on doorknobs and seeing
what opens oh so this is my fault
because I didn't lock my doors
in my own driveway
that does remind me
I was looking for my keys this morning I
couldn't find him
Atlanta was like we gotta go you got to
drop me off to school so I can walk in
front of some sunblind driver
and
I said well I can't find my keys go see
if the car is unlocked because if it's
unlocked the keys are in it
and that's what had happened
I don't so I'm not really learning from
my
mistakes here but I you know I got a
security camera installed point right at
that driveway so the next time somebody
steals my glasses or
my entire car because I left the keys in
it you get this I mean all you got to do
you know there's no ignition it's just a
button you open the door it's like well
I'm I'm just walking down the street
seeing pulling on doors man seeing what
opens then I'm sitting down in the seats
and I'm pushing the ignition seeing what
starts
putting it in Drive see what goes my car
this last night and all I would have had
is well it was semi-grainy
high angle footage
from the security camera I installed
when I learned my lesson from my
sunglasses and my regular glasses being
stolen
so yeah
all right I'm still learning my lesson
it's true
so my backup pair was gone and then my
main pair it was about another a a it
was a month later I went back to uh
the glasses shop and I said I need a
third pair because my second pair were
stolen and this is why I got the second
pair
so if they were stolen I would still
have a pair which I do and they're my
first pair
but now I need a third pair that is my
second pair we don't have them anymore
you know we only they only make a
certain amount and then it's that's why
these things are so cool and why you
like them because everybody can't get
them this isn't Warby freaking Parker
you know
they didn't have them we went on a hunt
for those guys and we went on a hunt for
those glasses everywhere I would go
looking for glasses because I was like
you know what I just need to diversify
and over the years I I've gotten I got
those buddy system clear glasses I got
some octagonal black glasses I then I
got some other black glasses that
sometimes I still wear at home
but it's like they just never took it
never took when something becomes that
much a part of your face when you take
them off and you put anything else I was
like whoa what's wrong what's wrong with
link man look at his face look how
blanket looks right now with no glasses
on and you put other glasses on it's
like who's that guy
and I was like I just gotta bite the
damn bullet and get some other glasses
and then I didn't
and then I didn't and then I didn't
like I got Lucas mad dog is like super
gluing my glasses I got Paisley dad
magic super glue in my glasses because
it would they would break and I was like
I've been just somebody's got the answer
I took them to a shop and paid too much
money for somebody to fix them and then
they re-broke and it was just like a it
was right there next to my my the bridge
of my nose it just could come just a
clean break
and I'm wearing them just now just
flopping around and I'm only wearing
them on camera and then everywhere else
I'm wearing other glasses I'm like this
is not who I want to be this is not my
ethos I don't want to be somebody on
camera and somebody else everywhere else
I don't want to be the pretend generic
version of Link off camera and then the
real
facially recognized link on camera like
I want to be able to look at my phone
and unlock it at all times I think that
works but
and then they just got more and more
precarious and it just like you could
see the brick and I just wasn't happy
with it and I was like I have to do this
I got to get these new I got to get some
new glasses
and as with everything it really comes
down to what Instagram sells me
um
Caddis c-a-d-d-i-s not a sponsor they
start you know I I started um I started
seeing their ads I saw these glasses
which I have these are called um
they they sell them as readers these are
the RCA
um
nowhere on the site does it say anything
about Jeffrey Dahmer
nowhere nowhere on the site
I was like I'm gonna get the brown ones
I'm gonna get to I'm gonna get the clear
ones and I'm very happy with these
glasses and yeah I was like I have to
commit I cannot read comments I am happy
with these and I am moving forward
you will catch up
or not it can't matter it just can't
it just can't so I got my old glasses in
like a
well they're in a Smithsonian ready case
I'm just going to put it to you that way
I have not received any calls any text
any emails I haven't been beeped by The
Institute but those glasses are in a
safe protected space I.E not the center
console of my unlocked car all right
uh and then I get these things and I
take them in for the to to my
optometrist to put the
um prescription in it and
he takes them from me he's like okay
what do you want and I was like I want
to freaking Progressive I gotta read
close then I gotta see far and I gotta
look old when I'm looking at the paper
under my nose like you know I read like
this
and um he said well there's something on
the top of these things it's like uh
Morse code
and I was like yeah I did notice that I
was like and I'm giving them to him so
I'm like
I ain't gonna take the time to
to try to decipher what that means at
this point in a transaction I got places
to be I'm a you know I'm an internet
celebrity
I made myself and my friend Famous by
doing what anybody could do which is
start a YouTube channel
so he said I said well
he said he's a nice guy he said
um I'll look it up and if it's something
questionable
uh I'll call you before we fill the
prescription I was like hey it's full
service and I never heard from him so I
go and pick these things up and try them
on I'm like okay and he you know he fits
them like
when you get glasses you gotta go you
you got to get to get the person
abandoned get the person to fit them you
know it's like don't just slam them on
and just walk out it's like there's some
bending that's got to happen because
you and I are the same we're humans our
ears aren't exactly in the same place on
either side of our head our heads aren't
the same on either side you know our
eyes might be in separate inside
slightly different places
the where it rests on your nose there
might be
you might have a skin tag
you know ain't no shame in that
got to get them adjusted I'm saving
lives today I'm feeling good now people
are getting their glasses adjusted man
that sucks
he said I looked up the morse code on
your glasses
it says Willie Waylon and then he hands
them to me and I was like what
really no he said Willie
Wayland that's just a that's a joke that
I just made up he didn't actually say
that
um
I was like
I could tell he didn't know what the
reference was so I was like
um have you you've heard of Willie
Nelson right he's like yeah Waylon
Jennings he was like uh I was like what
that's your loss man
legendary country music uh
masterminds and an iconic Duo so I'm
like this is perfect for me this is
freaking perfect I could I almost
couldn't have asked for uh I mean if if
I would have asked for it I think it
would have said Poncho and Lefty but
that's just that's me Caddis call me
let's get some Pancho and Lefty cooking
cooking up
and um it's they have all kinds but like
these rcas they I think they all say
Will and Waylon Willie so they don't say
anything again nothing about Dahmer and
then I'm get you know so
uh you know I don't care about those
comments cause I'm liking these glasses
when I get home every day
I will um
I'll take them off and then I'll put on
the other pair because they fit a little
bit different and it's
it's nice to uh it's kind of like when I
get home I like to I like to change
y'all like to change when you get home
I mean if you know you're not going
anywhere like I'll I'll put on I'll put
on a I put on some boxers and I'll put
on some sweatpants
and I'll put on
a night shirt
a shirt for the night
a soft little t-shirt something I have I
have my favorite T-shirts if they're
soft enough
they'll stick with me and they'll become
my night shirts
and I'll get into that when I get home
I'll get into getting into night mode
but changing my glasses it's like all of
a sudden your face feels like oh it's
the rest the glasses are resting in a
slightly different place and even the
two models they fit a little bit
differently so I kind of like to
I kind of like to get home and get a
little a fresh little Teeter
you know they Teeter up here on the
on the brim of my on the brim of my nose
anyway I digress
a lot
but I think it was worth it
I'ma sell you this uh hat
I'ma sell it to you mythical.com
it's um
it's a snapback
it's got It's got the fish netting
it's not full trucker hat so it's got a
little class
and it's got an embroidered GMM logo on
the front so eat your heart out
anyone who doesn't get them while
supplies last it's a nice just versatile
black cap
that um
you know if you don't feel like getting
your hair right
or it's not doing what you want it to do
throw on this mythical hat and you'll uh
you'll get the looks mythical.com
earbiscus is brought to you by
betterhelp you like to getting to know
people what if yeah those people are
yourself oh that's interesting you know
because you can get to know yourself in
therapy it's a great way to say oh
that's
why I do that that's and of course I do
that on this podcast a lot I try to
learn more about myself by bouncing
myself off of you yeah just like
um I also do that a lot in therapy and
it's extremely helpful yes therapy is a
great way to help you get a deeper
understanding of yourself because you're
always changing and evolving good point
uh and we're big fans of therapy can we
make that even more clear I don't think
so and we want therapy to be accessible
to everyone and so does better help yeah
you know one of the things that therapy
has been so helpful uh with me is that
there are these different roles that you
play in your life right so I'm a friend
I'm a husband I'm a father I'm a
business owner and sometimes when I
start talking about those different
roles that I play I'll find oh there's a
lot of anxiety or difficulty frustration
in this one thing and if I hadn't gone
to therapy had my appointment with my
therapist and actually talk through this
uh it would have just sat under the
surface and maybe gone unresolved for
weeks and who knows it began affecting
me physically I mean that happens with
me sometimes when I don't deal with
something
um right that's one of the things and
one of the areas that therapy has been
so helpful for me in yeah so if you're
thinking about starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
so you can have your sessions anywhere
you're comfortable and it's suited to
your schedule you just fill out a
questionnaire and they will match you to
a licensed therapist that meets your
specific needs and you can always switch
therapists at no extra cost so discover
your potential with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month let's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
[Music]
um
let's click on this one
hi link I was wondering what helps bring
you peace when you're feeling anxious as
an anxious being myself I really
appreciate your existence thank you so
much bye
oh
I only heard half that voicemail because
I was thinking oh this is a serious
question I got to use my real voice and
I'm like I don't think I was using my
real voice for the first part of this
podcast I think I was using I think I
was using an entertainer voice
how did that happen
these are the things that go through my
head constantly and I think that
um
that's
uh part I I think that's part of my
anxiety you know it's just like my
brain's kind of running on this like
strange gear that is not
um
it's not conducive to uh
sometimes it doesn't feel conducive to a
long life
you know it's if your brain's running
real hot
is it hot yeah it's a little bit hot
um
so what and so what did she ask
Ed she asked like what helps you when
you're feeling anxious oh just think
about it real hard just like just bear
down into it just think about how
anxious you can get and just like try to
try to make a downward spiral
oh you're so anxious
you're making me anxious
you know I never
I don't know I'm
I
it was hard for me to become convinced
that I had something that could have
like a a label to it
um
and I can't even remember the label
right now it's like it's like generic
anxiety disorders what it sounds like
that's not what it's called something
like that
um
I I feel like it really like it rears
its head when there's something coming
up that I have to do that I'm just not
like
I don't feel prepared for it but I gotta
go through with it like there's been a
lot of things in my life where it's like
you find yourself signing up for I mean
I and we have pursued so much in our
career that it it I found myself out of
my comfort zone a lot
and I think that's a good thing but it
really kind of highlights
where it went where where I start to
feel the most anxious and
uh in contrast to when things are out of
my control like that's easy for me to
um
just kind of check out well there's
nothing I can do about that anyway so
um why worry about it and I think that
happens subconsciously for me
and that's very
palpable because it's very obvious to me
in contrast to like and I've talked
about this before about how Christy is
has a as a flight anxiety and I love
flights because I'm in for the reason
that she hates them because I'm totally
out of control I can just like sit back
and say hey
this is not me it's why in that those
episodes that episode recently I was
saying I like to be handled because
it takes this pressure off that oh it's
up to me and you're gonna [__] it up
kind of a thing or this is the moment
where it all implodes
this is the moment when you climb in the
mountain and then you look up and it is
an avalanche coming down
I gotta stop watching this Avalanche
footage on Tick Tock like I don't know
why or it's Instagram or something I
think it's because I was like
I like snow skiing so then it's like oh
you like snow skiing well here's an
avalanche here's a POV shot of
somebody's GoPro and they're like and
they're always like
oh bro look at that
whoa
and then there's then it kind of changes
to oh it's I think it's gonna make it
here and it's like
and then they start moving and like
trying to hide behind something but
there's that first moment this is like
hey
I'm so glad I'm filming this
it's not gonna kill me it's too far away
and then that all changes
that's what anxiety feels like to me
sometimes when it's like oh I I got to
do this
um
so I try to
well
wanna and one of the things that is real
like that really lets me know that I'm
in an anxious period is when my heart
starts to skip beats that's at least
that's what I call it it's like you get
the heart flutter and
um
I've had it
definitely my entire adult life
so when I started my engineering job I
would come home I'd sit on the couch and
then I would start to I'd be like
watching Seinfeld or something like a
rerun
um
just relaxing
and all of a sudden it would be like my
my heart would
kind of
did my heart stop for a second uh what
just happened
and then
um sometimes I'll be like laying down in
bed and there's it'll it'll do it it and
I started over time to notice it more
and correlate it to times of like
extreme stress
um and then let's see at the beginning
of
2022 is when I started my started taking
Sertraline the generic version of Zoloft
um
uh work worked up to 50 milligrams and
uh
took that every day and
I just thought that in in combination
with being in therapy every week it
would be something uh that my doctor
recommended that I try and I was very
open to it and I you know I have
um close friends loved ones who have had
very positive experiences with uh ssris
for treating anxiety or depression and
so I was very open to it I just didn't
think that I was to the point where I
needed it and
um
but
I was having those heart palpitations
more I was kind of
uh
I don't know when you when I started to
get really anxious I started to get
pretty grumpy too you know it's like
that's not the that's not the me I want
to be
um and so I want to see how this can
help us part of my holistic treatment
plan not as a silver bullet but as as
part of it and I also anticipated that
uh 2022 was gonna be
a a challenging year even when I just
looked at it from a work
perspective
so I said you know what uh things are
only going to get more stressful this
year
because of reasons so I think that now's
a good time for me to kind of ramp up
and see how this works
um and that has been
a very good experience the thing that I
like about the heart palpitations is
that it's a pretty definitive
measurement like it it's hard times hard
sometimes to like
measure it's like you really got to pay
attention uh to whatever you're doing to
treat your anxiety to see if it's
helping you know basically like a a
daily mood Journal type thing it was
probably a really good idea
and it was hard for me to do but the
thing that made it easier for me was
I knew I wasn't having the heart
palpitations anymore so
um it kind of made it a cut and dried
victory for me
and then
uh you fast forward to the beginning of
this year
and
a lot of the things that from a business
standpoint that we were working through
and anticipating at the beginning of
last year I they they had kind of I we
had gone through that
and at the beginning of this year we
were entering a new phase that now we're
very much in which is
um just a creative realignment we've
been talking about it here on your
biscuits you've been seeing it on the
Rhett and Link channel you've been
feeling it
in good mythical morning and
um hopefully you're seeing it here right
now and just my level of ease
uh
I had zero anxiety about doing this
podcast by myself I think two years ago
or earlier
I would have been like my sweat boot
would have been smelling weird
you know how when you get a certain type
of stress and then all of a sudden it's
like what is that smell oh that's me
with a stress sweat type thing
um so the top of this year
with this new outlook and like a a
tweaked creative trajectory
um I was feeling like I was in a much
better place
um my therapy has been going really well
um and so you you might know what I'm
about to say and I think this is a
common thing
amongst in the in the world of like
anxiety medication is I was like maybe I
don't
need the medication anymore
maybe I don't
um but I didn't say hey maybe I don't
you know as if that would be some sort
of Victory
um
I did not look at it that way I think it
was an honest question in my mind of am
I in a am I entering a new season where
um
there's there's less stressors so like
my my low level anxiety is something
that through the other methods that I've
been working on
through breath work through therapy
through
um making sure that I have that I
protect my
time and space for things that
um
improve my mental health like walking my
dog
bipedal stimulation
uh riding my mountain bike bipedal
stimulation
bipedal that's I don't want to say that
word again bipedal two feet stimulate
two two sides of the brain being
simulated at the same time
um
if I employ all of those things and I
have the support of family friends
um I'm curious
if I went down on the medication what
would happen and then I went and I
talked to my doctor talked to my
therapist talk to talk to everybody and
you know it's
so I made the decision to do that to to
reduce my medication
uh starting like a couple months ago
and
um
I think that
I'm in a good place I don't you know
it's I
there's still that okay
am I gonna am I gonna have the heart
palpitations that if that comes back and
it hasn't then I know that I'm
definitely gonna go back
on the medication
but for me right now
I'm in a good place I'm having a good
experience
um
and uh so I I think I'm I think I'm
moving forward without the medication
for now
but uh
and I titrated off of it you know I was
working with a doctor on how to do that
so you don't just stop any of this stuff
you don't start or stop cold turkey
that's a bad bad bad idea
and so my doctor helped me understand
that
and um so yeah I feel like I'm gonna I'm
in a good place with all of these other
practices which is the answer to your
question
and um
but that may change again in the future
the the thing that I that I want to
reiterate
for me was that I didn't get off of it
off of some sort of guilt of like Oh I'm
a lesser person because I'm on a daily
medication
like we can we can fall for this
lie that
um you know if you're taking an SSRI
that you're that you're that you're less
for some reason
or that you don't have your [__]
together enough or fill in the blank
with any negative judgment
and
let's just let's just eradicate that
let's let's let's scrape that off the
table
um you know and forget about it
so I really
searched my heart to know that I felt
like my motivations were in the place
where I wanted them to be to move
forward with this
experiment
um and
I'm not experiencing like
I know some people if they go back off
of medication and they'll be like oh I
can I'm not numb anymore I can feel more
I I guess it I for whatever reasons
for me I I I'm not experiencing like
that I'm crying more and that I'm more
in touch with my emotions I I I don't
I don't think it was like that
um that I don't think it took those
things away from me or leveled that out
too much it was just more of
um that low level behind the scenes just
constant hum of tension
you know when they were that for me was
linked to
foreboding uh challenges
that I had to face
so
it's in my toolkit
I mean I I still have the pills I mean
like I'm not gonna I would talk to my
doctor and like still have guidance
before I move forward with going back on
it but for now I feel like I'm in a good
place so um that's that's this chapter
of my anxiety story what's uh let's go
to a tweet
tweeted are you ever gonna make more
music videos
music videos I can't read that right
can't are you ever gonna make more music
videos over on the Rhett and Link
channel come on go over to the Rhett and
Link channel
we dug a medium-sized hole it's not a
music video but there's a there's a song
in it and let me tell you what a what a
cat's away the mouse has been playing uh
red and I worked well we're working on a
new
uh rent link Channel video
um
when it does come out I'll give you a
hint so that like when it does come out
you'll know everything that I'm talking
about was related to it uh
it's
there's a year involved
I'll leave it at that
um
so
leading up to Red's vacation it's like
okay we decided we wanted to write a
song and put into
uh this video so it's not a music video
but at this point I'm I mean we haven't
shot the video
um we're still writing writing the song
that goes in the video but uh as soon as
Ray gets back from um vacation
we got like one day back in the office
to hopefully record some vocals and then
the next day we're going out and we're
filming this thing in one day that's the
plan
I am
I am so excited
uh
creatively but with what we're doing on
the red Link channel because it's
getting us reacquainted and getting me
reacquainted with uh writing recording
producing music and I don't know that
you'll call uh called this one a music
video either but because we're throwing
so many different things at it it's I
don't know it's it's got
some similarities to the whole video in
that there's a music
video-esque part to it
um
but before left we had to kind of cram
at the last minute and we were like okay
we got some chords we're like gonna demo
this song out and I was like I'm gonna
I'm gonna take this thing while you're
gone I'm gonna keep writing lyrics
and we can work on it remotely as much
as you want to be in touch and be
involved
um we can still collaborate on this
thing but I got this
uh while you're gone I'm excited to be
to like bring this song further along
but we needed to get a chorus before I
mean it's like the course is the most
important part we can just we can like
hum some gibberish for the verses just
to give Mark our producer an idea of how
to like build the song
the chorus is something we need to like
we kind of need to nail down together
because it's just really important and
it was set where this thing goes and we
only had like a two hour window
and
that's a good kind of pressure because
it's exactly what I want to be working
on and
I I don't know if there's a more
exhilarating feeling
in my job then
having a musical breakthrough and I've
I'd missed that for so long like we had
we'd gotten out of of writing songs and
getting back into it and like having
these moments where I just I'm feeling a
breakthrough like whoa whoa whoa it just
happened it's happening right now what
what we just came up with
is is is is good this is gonna
this is what we're hoping for
you know it's like you sit down with the
chords and it's kind of a blank slate
and I I have this feeling I don't think
Rhett has this feeling
I have this feeling again that that
anxiety thing I was talking about it's
like
come up with something I really hope we
come up with something
and then it's this relief and release
when it's like
we did it we got it that's it that's the
spark now the thing that I was so
excited about I'm pretty sure it's not
going to change but even if it did it
wouldn't change the fact that in that
moment like that experience is like
Nothing's Gonna top that there's other
parts of there's a lot of parts of my
experience that are just as exhilarating
but not I don't think they're more
exhilarating
than that for me and so are we gonna
make more music videos absolutely are we
gonna write more songs definitely and
this like so
I was working on the demo yesterday and
I sent it out to the team and I haven't
heard back from Rhett I guess he was 60
feet under
scuba diving yeah
if you're six feet under your dad if
you're 60 feet under your uh you're
swimming he went to he went to Costco
got a
um yeah
I just love that feeling you know it's
and especially you know in my like in
over the past couple of years like
really
uh Fanning the flame of my passion for
music in general
and now going back to it
to writing music it just feels it's an
even more rewarding experience
um
Erica with k
did I give you that
nickname
Erica
I'd like to think I did
uh Erica tweets since I always seem to
put my foot in my mouth when I meet you
yeah we met a few times
what's your go-to recovery when you find
yourself in your own foot in mouth
situation I've never been in that
situation I've never put my foot in my
mouth I mean I'm flexible but
I mean that'll never happen to me I
never I never start speaking without
knowing where the sentence is gonna end
you know
I don't know what you're talking about
I was um
I was at a
I'll call it a kickback
it I uh
uh we were at a party it wasn't our
party but we were somehow invited so we
go red and I went to this part uh went
to a birthday party like a sit-down
dinner
after the dinner part was over everybody
was still sitting down and just kind of
having some drinks and talking and so we
show up
with a group of people that invite who
were invited that invited us to go with
them so like we show up and like I guess
some people when dinner's over some
people left the party they had other
places to be so there were open seats I
felt a little weird about it but um we
sat down at the end of the table me
Andra and then across from us a friend
of mine and then his friend that I just
met who happened to be like a really
established
songwriter and producer
um
and I would
I was kind of piecing that together it's
like sometimes when you meet people who
are like
really the [__] in whatever because of
whatever they do it's like you're not
gonna know it because when you're really
the [__] you're not gonna they don't
stink you're not gonna you're not gonna
you're not gonna smell it because it's
like they're securing themselves they're
just they're just there because they're
they want to be there they're not there
so that you will know who they are
so I'm kind of piecing it together Erica
and
I'm like okay this is a fun opportunity
for me to spark up a conversation with
this super successful songwriter
and uh I mean he's got nobody to talk to
but me and Rhett and our other friend
anyway we're down here at the end of the
table
and um oh my God I gotta this is my
moment I gotta come up with something
and I knew that they had he had been
doing some writing
uh that day in the preceding couple of
days
and so I was just like
so
what's a what's the line that you came
up with that you're particularly proud
of
I'm like this is I'm I'm legitimately
interested in this it's about him it's
not about me and it's
um
I really yeah it's like uh I don't know
what the other thing is but I was like
okay this is this is good enough but
like I was coming out I was just like
well nobody's talking I'm just I'm gonna
come up with this question
it it it it didn't land as well as I
thought it would like I don't know it
just seemed maybe a little
in too journalistic
I could think it I could think it into
pieces the point and I don't know the
reason but he didn't
he didn't have an answer you know it
wasn't like oh this is making him light
up like my goal was to spark
conversation that got him to light up
because I want to enter his world a
little bit you know it's like I'm always
in mind
and um I don't know that he wants to he
hasn't asked me about mine so I'm just
not going to start volunteering that
information because I seem like a dick
um but that didn't really work and I was
kind of embarrassed because it was just
like oh did I is that not something
you're supposed to ask
and I'm like
I don't listen to that voice that's not
a good voice to listen to it met my
criteria I was interested and it was
others Focus too so there you go
but then I had to regroup so I didn't I
wouldn't say that was I put my foot in
my mouth because it was a decent
question right it just I think when
you're a songwriter it it it it's a hard
question to answer and not maybe maybe
he was thinking well I okay how am I
going to answer this question and not
seem like a dick well I wrote this line
and
wasn't it awesome you know it's like so
then I switched it up and I had to make
it a little bit about me and Rhett and I
was like you know we've been talking
about
um
our creative process and making sure
that we take time to stop and celebrate
um the little
especially the little moments like the
one that I was just celebrating with you
about
um just that spark in the songwriting
process and how it just I can ride that
wave for this entire week
um and finish the song like that's what
I needed to uh to do my part to finish
the song is get that jolt
so we start talking about that and then
I'm like when you're in a studio and
you're you're writing and you're in the
moment and you're like making this
happen like
what is that feeling for you like what
are those moments for you when you start
to feel like
magic is happening
and then I got him because his his eyes
started he started to perk up a little
bit
and he was engaged and
um he was just talking about
his the process and that feeling and
like the thing that keeps him after all
these years of being super successful at
it
that keeps him engaged and chasing that
feeling and how it's separate from an
audience response or it's separate from
external
uh recognition
basically the stuff that retina and I
talked about at this table weeks ago
when we were talking about
um the whole video before it came out
like having that conversation within
with another artist
and um so I was able to Pivot I don't
know what
you can glean from that Erica but
um maybe it's um don't
well I think when you put your
foot in your mouth it's like if you're
I don't know I always tend to err on the
side of like giving it a shot you know
it's uh you can always pivot there's
always a second question you can go in a
different direction
um
and it's especially if you're if you're
if you're not making it about you or and
or not making about the fact that you
felt like you put your foot in your
mouth it's like if if you're sincere and
if you're engaged and if you actually
care I think that that type of thing
comes through
um
so just ride on that wave
wait there's so many questions and I'm
not I'm going so slowly because I'm such
a such a motor mouth
Christina also with a K asks what was
the first thing you thought when you met
Christy oh let's talk about Christy
um if you've heard the story Chris and I
met uh in line waiting to go into a
roller rink for a Christian College
social
it's getting hot in here so put on some
roller skates
um
she had gone there early she was in
basically the front of the line with her
group of girlfriends from the all girls
college
and I got there late
which allowed me to
peruse the entire line of people waiting
to go in and yeah she caught my eye
I mean she was a wonderful looking
person to me
especially and she I just and she had
this personality that like that matched
it like just jumping just jumping out of
the lot like she was probably jumping
she's probably or maybe she was clogging
she wasn't wearing clogs but she'll
break out into a clog
like don't mess with a girl who knows
how to clog
that is a dance
for any plumbers out there who just
perked up
please
sorry
it's it's like a country line dancing I
don't know meets
[Music]
Swedish people
Dutch people I don't know
I don't ask questions it's it's a lot of
it's from the hips down it's kind of
like it's it's a little river dance-ish
anyway she wasn't actually doing that
but she was um she seemed to be the
ringleader of her friend group she was
outgoing
um she was funny and she had an accent
of the Southern variety that made me
melt
and she didn't know how to roller skate
and I said oh I can fix that so
um yeah I taught her how to roller skate
it was super romantic
um I tripped her on purpose and then she
grabbed my big ass stove pipe pant leg
and pulled me down with her
um and we made it right there in front
of all the Christians
laughs
it was awesome
it was sweet
I love the fact that I and we had just a
picture of us from that night that like
floats around
we'll dig it up and I can show it right
now
our styles were very different
um she was she was preppy J crew and I
was um
alternative
Rock wannabe
um
Laney asks me if you could have a true
Bromance with anyone on the crew other
than Rhett who would it be
who would it be who would it be
um
I I got a little bit of a bromance with
Ben like Ben's my my DJ buddy we hang
out we listen to music with we'll we'll
spin the Wheels of Steel together we'll
trade notes uh sometimes that'll happen
yeah
um
uh
Chase is my buddy he's my scuba buddy
and now um now that Rhett and Shepard
are getting into that he's not
disinvited
red still got to earn his way on on the
squad because uh Chase is my go-to scuba
buddy
um I can't have a bromance with Stevie
but she she won't invite me over to pet
her dog
I don't know what gives
I don't know what the holdout is
but I could I don't think I could have
been more blatant about it
than than my tweet
of course it turns out that she wasn't
on Twitter anymore for like years maybe
that brought her back on Twitter
um
Jenna you and I got a little bit of a
bromance going on here you know it's
like uh you can't you can't work
like you you we work as closely as
anybody beside me and Rhett so it's like
I mean it's like this wouldn't work if
we didn't like each other
um but we don't have any out out of
out of the office Hobbies together right
maybe that's healthy for you
right okay I get it I'd say listen we've
we've survived uh terrible flights
together oh my God that's bonded us more
than anything oh yeah all that travel
and like going on tour and stuff oh yeah
it's like that that's uh that's that's a
special type of bond and then when like
yeah when you almost get slammed into
the runway
yeah wasn't there for that
um
I tell that story occasionally because
you know there's always the like the
flight story comes up everybody has
their flight horror stories
and um yeah we were we were trying to
land in a hurricane yes yeah and like
you know sometimes you'll hit we weren't
the the pilots we were just we were I
was I was gritting and I was gritting in
my teeth I was I was trying too I
accepted I accepted my fate I like put
on some Dolly Parton and I was like if
this is how it goes How It Go I mean
yeah because one of you know if you're
flying all of a sudden you hit this air
pocket and then you're like you lose
elevation and then it's just like you're
free falling for a second that's scary
but when you're landing and that happens
that's really scary and then we're like
okay is this thing gonna
are we gonna do a back flip and then
land is this like is the pilot trying to
make an Olympic move here I I too I love
that I'm glad that I told the complete
fresh juicy version of the story here on
your biscuits you have to dig that one
up because I can't remember it like I
did then but I remember enough of it to
know that like we did we got as close as
you can get to landing and then so he
took off again yeah and then we landed
at another Airport
and we got off of the plane and then you
were like
I don't know if you said anything but
all I remember now this version of the
story is you disappeared I did and then
when you came I was like when we came
back to get on the other flight
I was like what where you been you're
like I'm I'm I've been at the bar
yeah yeah
you got you got in line for food and um
yeah and you were like in line waiting
for food with everyone and I was like
uh well I'll I'll be back like I'm not
hungry I went to the bar and then took
two two shots of whiskey immediately I
went out to a bartender like what do you
need us like whiskey that was a it was
the worst flight experience I've ever
had so it's like yeah we we'll always
have that
bro
the beautiful sunset after the almost
crash and then you remember that I
remember that I remember I I remember
the almost Landing that didn't happen
and then we had to go to another airport
and we went up above the clouds and it
was like the prettiest Sunset ever saw
him whole life
and you were drunk that was that was
before that that was before oh yeah yeah
okay all right fair enough fair enough
what what's the can't miss for you here
before we uh before we get I know
there's well I wanted to hear about the
rapid fire thing I want to hear the
Bromance because I I hoped you would say
that I was one of those which you did so
that I was well you were I mean you were
you were giving me this this
the sad eyes the sad eyes you guilted me
into it bro he said Ben he said Chase
he's like even look over at me
who else am I missing who's listening to
this and saying I thought I thought I
was your bro
so before we go into rapid fire what
what else I mean
what else is the good one
um
I'm I'm trying to remember what uh this
uh this uh Erica who has a c Erica is
lost in the music I'm trying to remember
what they're talking about from
September oh
I think I know I feel kind of silly at
for asking but back in September y'all
were each gifted
something
uh you said you'd give your opinion on
your experience with it but I don't
think you ever did inquiring minds want
to know about that butt plug
uh I figured Rhett would be really open
to discussing
um yeah
I'll tell you
um
I've got I've got a report
um but you're gonna have to wait till
September to hear it I'm sorry I didn't
mean to leave a big teaser but uh yeah
you know I can't be talking about that
without my without my buddy back in his
saddle over there
because of what it is like that just
seemed weird to say it that way yeah
it's the same all right so you're gonna
have to wait on that one too Jenna you
don't have to wait
y'all
yeah and I'll have more you know as time
passes I'll have more to tell
mm-hmm
all right let's see is there any other
what is this let's click on this
voicemail
hey link my name is Aaron I'm from San
Jose California
um I know that you love mountain biking
and so my question to you as a fellow
mountain biker myself is just what kind
of bike do you ride and what are some of
your favorite trails in the LA area
have a great day
oh man why why I can't even remember the
type of bike that I ride like here's the
thing about me and the stuff
when I do the things like yeah I love
mountain biking I I've I think I might
be able to get on it this afternoon
um
I honestly
can't remember what brand it is I think
it's a specialized
um but you know for a price it can be
anything
you know so
come at me mountain bike people let's
work together
um but yeah I'm not typically I'm like
my friend Nick is like my number one
mountain biking buddy and one of the
great things about Nick is that
he
whenever he gets into something he knows
everything about it and I like being the
guy with the person who knows everything
about it you know
again it's just like it takes the
pressure off like I don't have to worry
about what pressure I should ride my
tires at or if I start to get this
squeak like what what do I do about it I
don't even have to search Reddit because
I got I've got a buddy
so Nick's got my back and it's um
I mean I'm not using the guy uh he's a
good friend we enjoy riding together
um
but it certainly is an added benefit to
be like hey what type of bike do I have
again he's like uh I he probably knows
everything about my bike in addition to
his bike and the places to go and
um but in terms of the places to go I've
got a few I've got like a
45 minute ride that I can do and then I
got a two hour ride that I can do and
then there's other places around but I'm
kind of a creature of habit so I kind of
tend to stick to those two places and I
ain't gonna tell you where they are
you know the two-hour ride is the one
where I broke my collarbone and um
I think there was another question in
here about
about the collarbone and my recovery
from that
yeah from uh hippie counselor what what
is that yeah what has your experience
been
like uh post wreck in regards to getting
active again
breaking my collarbone was was a big
setback at the end of the year I
anticipated it being the type of thing
that like it made my top 10 of the year
because uh
I don't know it's just it's had all
these Ripple effects in terms of like me
continuing to be active again like uh
you know 10 weeks is a long time to to
not
be doing stuff like that you love like
getting on your bike and
so I'm actually still working up like
trying to rebuild my cardio I haven't
done the two hour run
yet
like
maybe I'll do it today maybe I'll do it
this weekend so you know here we are in
April and I'm still
he's still recovering from like that
getting to a point where I can get back
to where I was
Thanksgiving of last year
and that does have an impact on on how I
ride a little bit I mean it's
I've I've tried to take the pressure off
myself and say I'm slowly working myself
back up and I'm not I'm not I'm not
doing anything really crazy and I
haven't gone on anything yet
like when I go on the two hour ride
there'll be a couple there'll be the
place where I had the accident I don't
know what I'm gonna do I think I might
take a 40 up there and just pour it out
pour one out for my
for my old collarbone configuration
I'm not gonna drink any of it I'm gonna
pour it all out
and then I'm gonna keep going up then
I'm gonna come back down but there's a
couple of places in there where coming
back down it'll get tedious but like the
thing that I learned is you got to have
your guard up you got to be present
pretty much you can't zone out too much
because
when you're at speed like it just can't
allow myself to do that that's a lesson
that I learned
um and when I'm going back down I'm I'm
gonna be more cautious because I'll be
thinking about like is it worth the
additional thrill of going that much
faster here taking a little bit of a
risk
to then be knocked off my game for
another 10 to 12 weeks
and I got off easy
you know like
I wasn't in a lot of pain like I feel
like
it was the best way for me to learn that
lesson but I've been on my bike enough
to discover that I don't I don't have a
fear I don't have a newfound uh
like fixation with falling
um which is a relief because I was kind
of concerned about that I was like and
then two days ago was the first time
that I got back on the one wheel and
that
I mean
mountain biking there's a certain
there's certain zones where you gotta
really be present
um but when you're on that one wheel you
kind of always have to have your guard
up a little bit more so I've been more
nervous to get back out on that thing
but um after going snowboarding and
skiing I was like okay I'm gonna do this
and uh it was fun it was fun
because when when Lando uh took a fall
and broke his wrist he got on the one
wheel a few more times but then he
basically hung it up like I just
couldn't
he was a lit he just like he couldn't
get loose enough to enjoy it after that
and um
I'm just glad that didn't happen to me
that's where I'm at
um let's do some
let's do some rapid fire I want I want
you to just read them and then I'm just
gonna like
answer okay well it's such a strange
world we live in like that I operate in
like there's so much of like ask me
anything kind of Vibes you know it's
like the fact that
I don't know sometimes I just think what
a
what a strange position to be in where
if it's like
hey
I'm gonna talk for over an hour about me
and I and you're interested so ask me
about me
you know isn't that
that's why uh that's why I had the idea
for the get I had I had a guest I was
excited about having on this episode
because I'm not as I'm not really a fan
of all of this
ask me about me stuff it's like
I don't know
I had fun though
I did have fun
and I I do really appreciate the
interest the fact that I can like take a
device type out
I'll answer any questions
you got if you're interested and then
you got all these people asking me
questions
and then they want they want me to talk
about myself I don't know I feel better
saying what I just said given everything
that I've already said
and I think that's why I said it
but the guess that I was going to have
on
um I still want to make that happen
that's going to happen right yeah we're
gonna we're gonna make that happen
all right so uh enough about me
let's talk some more about me
rabid fire this time I hate rapid fire
okay from Chicago Mark should the name
Sarah end with an H or not
uh yeah and it should be pronounced
Sarah it's there it's there it's just
like there should be an H in white
because it needs to be pronounced I
cannot say it in my house without people
just
just laying into me
white white there's an H in it Sarah
[Laughter]
Sarah
oh
love that song
from Rebecca Bryson
Rebecca Rebecca Rebecca
Rebecca Bryson mu uh the tuck did it
hurt
oh you're talking about
um
when you
go drag I don't know if it's called go
drag I'm still learning
um
you I was I learned to do the tuck
uh no it wasn't
um
it wasn't
that bad wasn't that bad
I was also wearing like
I think it was eight layers of tights
and so my toes were like already like
smushed and then I crammed my foot into
a high high heel shoe and that is
painful pain is beauty painful with an H
painful so I think I was distracted from
um my testicles being being somewhere
like up in my bladder in my my my my
wiener
pointing folded back on the taint I'm
not going to be more specific than that
because uh that was more specific than I
anticipated I'd say that's pretty
specific sorry
at Taco Bell is good favorite fast food
joint in and out
I mean it's got to be
that when I when I feel like I really
want to treat myself that's the first
thing I think of
okay once upon a life asks what is a
trait you value most in other people
I'm an echo something server I think
sincerity you know I think if you
is that I'm sure that's not the only one
I there's got to be at least three other
ones that tie with that but that's what
I'm going with today
you know
don't give me lip service
mean it want it
put your heart into it
at fomal Haute 333 okay uh pass a heart
maybe formal hot 333 uh what's your
ideal me time and activity you enjoy
doing alone other than mountain biking
other than mountain biking
um am I alone if I'm with my dogs
petting my dog is is my number one Hobby
um number two is probably mountain
biking what else do I like to do alone
um
I mean definitely listen to music I mean
no news there like headphones it up lay
in bed
grab a new album
and just go with it I'll give you my
wreck now since it ties into that uh
Larry June and The Alchemist released an
album called The Great Escape and I'm
obsessed with this with The Alchemist
this guy
yeah he conjures it's he's got a great
moniker because like it's um the vibe
that he conjures is so
laid I I really like the laid back stuff
and uh if you just concentrate on what
he's done and then you're like okay what
if I was a rapper and then I
had to lay something over top of this
what on Earth would I do
and then I think that will that helps
unlock
just the uh
this the the magnetic
uh collaboration
between
him and Larry June when like with what
he's what he's putting over top of that
like
I I love to think about that you think
about how something was made and it's
like when you take something apart and
you isolate it and then you try to
decide how was how did how did they
Inspire each other to put this together
and it's um
it's it's a vibe it's a Vibe it's a fun
album cover too I would just buy it just
for the album cover
uh and I think I'm gonna do that
because I'm now justifying my album
purchases as also decoration
you know when you think about oh I'm
gonna buy this piece of art to go on my
wall it's like well if you're gonna drop
you know
yeah you could drop 40 you could drop 40
60 on like something you're gonna hang
on you on you're gonna look at it again
and again and again and again
and um and I had it all wrong I'm like
I'm thinking I'm thinking so frugally
like I do I'm like well I gotta really
really like this album and I gotta
really commit to sitting on a listen to
it on the vinyl and I got to do this and
I gotta do that to justify the purchase
now I'm just saying no it's a cool
looking album and it means something to
me so I'm going to hang it up I think
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna change out
my albums at the creative house it's
like they've been the same too long
next that was that was real quick
keep on with the music so at uh Charon
Joelle what artists that are alive you
haven't seen in concert and you wish you
could see
um I would like to see Tupac open for
the Beatles
okay same person different question what
song would you consider perfect or
almost perfect I'm always on a mountain
when I fall the reason why it's not
perfect is because Merle didn't actually
write it but that performance and the
production makes it my favorite my
favorite
and last question is uh from the same
person is there a song that makes you
instantly happy
uh
it's Gotta Be Easy Lover Philip Bailey
Phil Collins
that's I mean you hear that opening
riff and it gives you Goosebumps back in
that episode of Good Mythical Morning
way back in the day when we were like we
tried to like to give ourselves
Goosebumps and that was easy for me just
playing that song
that's that's Happy mode activated
metallic almonds asks link what is your
preferred method for cleaning your
glasses both at home and out on
adventure I haven't settled on anything
great yet we got these alcohol wipe
thingies that are like they look like
condoms
right and um
well they the package looks like a
condom package I'm not sitting there
wiping my glasses with a condom
uh but interestingly enough that when I
that is my other answer just uh
lubricated condom
no that wouldn't work
um nothing beats
hot hot water and dish soap and then
an Ultra Clean dry
towel
but honestly I end up using uh paper
towel I think people people say don't
use a paper towel but
nothing is going to get my glasses
cleaner than hot hot water and some Dawn
liquid dish soap and you
you went and you wash the whole glass
watch every part of the glasses don't
just wash the lens
because this it's been through it and
when it gets stolen out of your car
you're gonna want them to be clean it's
like damn this is the cleanest glasses
I've ever stolen they're not my
prescription I don't know what I'm gonna
do with them that's the sad thing about
that story is that like
what did they do with my glasses like
they were just trying to find like high
dollar sunglasses of which mine they
took as well but their prescription and
odds are they're worthless to you you
jackass
you they
he or she
probably or they I don't know your
pronouns but I hate you
laughs
for stealing my glasses and then you
probably just threw them away
when you put them on you were like oh my
God instant headache both pair like
that's the irony is that you stole my
glasses
and they were good for no one else
like
I don't know I guess you can pop out the
lenses and like take them and get them
replaced with something but you think
some like Petty cul-de-sac Thief is
gonna do that no
they're just gonna Chuck them
I probably could have walked down the
street and if it was trash day I'll
probably get a look through all those
trash cans and found my damn classes
see what you've done Jenna you put me in
a mood play Easy Lover oh God play it
I gotta put you in a there's a I'll give
you a better question well not a better
their question wasn't bad just let's
give you a question I think you did
answer it yeah paper towels that's what
you need
uh from Hannah
a Perkins
I got a good one if you could own any
animal in the world as a pet the animal
is domesticated and will not kill you
what animal would you own
a white tiger to protect the glasses to
protect the freaking class
I don't
I don't know who this guy is on
platforms
that's like wrestling with tigers and
pretending to be Tarzan and there's a
Tar this is the type of [__] that retino
is about but and I don't care for it but
it does come across my feet this guy
just like loving up on tigers and I'm
jealous I am jealous
I mean to have that much power just to
like you are the pet
like you become the pet like can I
snuggle up with you in your bed like I
like the idea of that
just like getting lost in the arms of a
tiger
a tame tiger
I love that idea
I mean I bet you suck it
see Jade is like the
Jade is the softest dog ever and I love
her because she's so soft but you know
what
Osaka the cat is softer than Jade
I got to be real
now he doesn't
cuddle or snuggle usually
and uh
but I just got to think that like a well
groomed tiger
I would just
man I would just like to just crawl up
crawl up and next to the belly at that
tiger in this you know the I said it was
a white tiger but I take it back I'm
gonna say like a
orange Bengal tiger they're so beautiful
and they got that white belly that's the
human spot that's where the human sleeps
the pet human
like I'd be on it I'd be on a leash for
that [__]
thanks for listening
um hashtag your biscuits
let me know what you think about
anything let me know what you think
uh and of course you can always leave us
a voicemail one eight eight eight earpod
one this is fun thanks for the support
Jenna Jamie Brett you suck man you suck
dude you suck
I link I hope you're having a good solo
episode I I was calling to say that over
the last six to eight months as someone
who enjoys all of the content that you
put out I just want to say that I have
noticed a a really distinct difference I
think and and you from uh when you kind
of started your your therapy and when
you started talking about your
medication with anxiety
um and who you are now and I just think
it really shows
um that you've grown into a much Fuller
person and I say that with no uh
disrespect to your former self but I
just want to say that it was it's really
inspiring as someone else who deals with
anxiety on a general basis to see you
grow into someone that you're completely
comfortable as and completely happy at
so thank you so much for everything you
do I really appreciate it bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]